is it appropriate that MPS are  manhandled  I I uh well as I say I wasn't there but  I have seen not the point the  photographs but just right it's going to  be much easier if you answer the  question let me answer the question okay  I will uh I don't think it's ever  acceptable uh for uh any party and we  have seen this happen before where uh  whips perhaps uh overeg uh their  encouragement to get people to vote in  the appropriate way that is that is  never right the one thing that our  Parliament is uh so uh revered around  the world for us that we allow each of  us to vote with our conscience and  indeed with our government on important  matters